好的
朝心口开箱
为什么呢
骗你这意思吗
好我再看看还有谁哦
呵呵好
OK美乐哦耶yes
我爱上渣美乐
大家还记得这个偶像剧吗
美乐摘下耳返递麦
我也可以直接递呀
OK好好
我快速的
因为我常常都会希望把大家的这个板板啊
这个这个牌灯牌连念完
我快速睫毛弯弯
眼睛眨啊眨
心能撑到80岁呀
好我努力保持健康
80岁我总是问说唱到80岁
你们舍得吗
结果你们都还给我舍得
好OK生日是不是生日快乐
老公是不是要哦
OK我觉哦不还我不知道
我想想看
我考虑一下
在心里只当幸福一辈子
祝你幸福
想看心凌姐姐什么左边也留
左边也留刘海
你自己留吧
我喜欢怎么样
我眼睛这么大
管我刘海有
是不是呀
哎呀不用这样子
OK今天是我来了
你的第哦
你来了可以看了20场啊
哇哇天哪
知道吗
今天杭州战事是被害的第60场了耶
我的天哪
我觉得是一个很棒的数字
这60场有20场的参与
谢谢你的参与
谢谢你
OK爱你爱你
刚分手
求王姐安慰
分手多久了多久了
分手多久
刚分手一天
一天是明天就和好了吧
社会的球不会是为了球安会长分手的吧
好了
就算是喜欢会长分手
我也祝福你好不好
希望你有个那个美好的爱情好
六岁的年年想要听年年年年嗨
年年拜年
年年年年年嗯
哦好可爱哦好可爱哦
金属于你
然后周末想和你约会
呃爱你
21年在东莞等我
是不是呃
我们的女儿女儿在哪儿啊
女儿在哪儿
女儿没在你们的女儿啊
那她有来吗
下次大家来看我好不好
OK西柚有吃西湖醋鱼吗
早就吃啦
我之前在这边拍戏拍了一个多月了
该吃的都吃了
OK这边也有20场的
贼个香宜也有20场
其他还有好色山东
欢迎您好
OK我这边到有绍兴的朋友在心里心心相印
这边是发生了什么事呢
二三楼的朋友稍等我一下
我很快的啊
看这边好多灯牌
我的天哪
好多牌子
你们是这有备而来的
我的天
你昨天你又来了
从那边来了
天津的朋友
他郑州的时候也在来了哦
你昨天诶好像也在这
对对对对对您
您今天也是用洗面奶洗这吗
好好好
我看我把号
我把你点一下
我怕我剪不完
下班喝酒吗
我请哈哈哈啊
我会自己准备的
哈哈好
这边是天津的柠檬
贵州的
浙江的柠檬
陕西的柠檬
上海的柠檬从台北飞到杭州
嗨
欢迎来欢迎来到杭州
台北的朋友
香港的朋友
上海的honey
广东的柠檬
长安城的月光等等
很着急
好努力努力哈
上海球返场好
也努力哈
好如果哦
如果我不理你
你就哭给我看
那你哭吧
你哭我看看有拍到他吗
好啦我理你了啦
这边也有人为什么那么喜欢走
朝你开枪啊
QQOK我都念完了
对不对
心凌姐
然后这边有小宝贝
心灵姐姐
你是三岁的小粉丝哈
嗨皮痒的哈尼
从杭州刚靠演唱
从郑州刚看完演唱会就临时被逮回去加班哦
辛苦啦
所以我已经安慰你了
对不对
好台州的朋友快
还有那四川的朋友
OK第3年的生日快乐
我跟你讲哦
我真的是点到点不完
是不是还有二楼的朋友啊
这里OK手写的生日快乐
OK生日快乐
爱爱你
那这边是不是还有什么呢
好好的
我很尽力的这个奶茶
我请够嗨好
我看到你了
我很尽力的想要把大家的灯牌都念完
然后能够跟大家有更多的互动
所以刚才都在几乎都在跟一楼的朋友互动
那二楼的朋友你们还好吗
包厢跟天上的朋友
你们还好吗
杭州全场的朋友你们都好吗
谢谢你们今天的热情
我们一样要继续保持这样子的活力
好不好好不好
我们继续唱歌好吗
唱好听的歌
觉得这首歌听到前奏应该应该是有印象
给他会的
你们要帮我动动动动动动动动动动动动动